hä das ist doch gar nicht erlaubt oder
für die einen ist er voll für die Tonne
für die anderen eine kreative
geschwindigkeitsüberwachungsanlage der
mülltonnenblitzer aus dem Kreis
Rendsburg-Eckernförde ich dachte mal
weil die waren doch auch mal in diesen
Säulen die an der Straße stehen ist es
nicht so dass ein Blitzer eigentlich
klar ersichtlich sein muss also das ja
wohl eine Frechheit wird heißt
diskutiert er ist super getarnt und wird
meist viel zu spät entdeckt ist das
Verkehrsüberwachung zum Zwecke der
Unfallprävention oder einfach nur gut
getante Abzocke also grundsätzlich
denken wir natürlich dass das
vorhandenen ortungsämtern dafür
bereitgehalten werden sollte für
Sicherheit zu sorgen und eben auch für
Verkehrssicherheit und nicht dafür
Blitzer möglichst originell zu
verstecken es hat immer ein geschmeckt
das ist hier nicht mehr um
Verkehrssicherheit geht sondern um ab
das können wir nachempfinden also das
finde ich auch ist ja eine bodenlose
Frechheit wenn der mich Blitz würde so
die Mülltonne umtreten ne wie früher
okay ich habe jetzt mal gegoogelt
anscheinend ist das wirklich erlaubt
aber weiß ich nicht